here we go with t-more rajabos top five
moves this is the top fives we got the
candidates coming up we gotta see
teamwork too right here it is okay first
this first game is teamwork or job off
versus boom zhang zai um so okay like to
move what do you do in this position
pause the video if you need to of course
we're going to sit here we're going to
take stock into position what do you do
why to move okay here we go right timor
rajabov has two bishops a queen and a
rook versus two bishops a queen and a
rook we have an open f file we got some
work to do there there is some things to
do but it feels like white's attacking
obviously right well that's on you to
figure out what to do it is right to
move in this position what do you do
and here we go here we go here's the
move here so
well let's look around bishop takes e6
is obvious right i mean we can't take
this but then what's the follow-up
because bishop takes g4 is a real threat
he's about to take this right and i mean
we don't really have the attack yet like
we can't get in there yet he has
everything covered right
so what rajaboff says is well when you
have everything covered then you said
something that's what you're supposed to
do
you sack something right it's in the
book so rick f7 played immediately wow
what a move rook f7 crushing him putting
the rook on the seventh ring well it can
just be captured
really i mean it can be but bishop takes
d7 all right this is the whole idea rook
takes rooks uh rook f7 is beautiful
because it's putting pressure on the
seventh rank saying go ahead please take
my bishop on g4 also it's like okay well
there's no mate so what happens if i
take the bishop on g4 which is what
happens in the game it is right to move
what is your intention of this cool
little rook f7 movie made oh great right
yeah that was cool you couldn't i
couldn't take it because my queen was
hanging but if i take your bishop what
do you do now
well here's the move where drive off
says huh gotcha big fella here's the
move in fact
let's see what you guys have
rook takes g7
is not it that's not the move
you lose impact game over start a new
game rotate g7 does nothing after
hearing take okay you got your little
child that's cute oh you got your little
check that's cute
you can resign too resign on the way out
thank you right there's nothing else
there's nothing left literally so after
rook takes g7 doesn't work so in fact
the move here is bishop
oh my goodness
send them a stretcher right bishop takes
a bishop f6 what a move here oh my
goodness it hurts right after bishop
takes f6 there's queen h7 mate
beautiful right so that's obvious so the
only way to capture this and of course
also there's uh this threat here of rook
takes g7 also bishop takes g7 in many
cases here right it's really rough stuff
like if you see a rook g8 here by the
way roch8 is a nice defense but you have
rook takes e7 i mean this is a disaster
i don't know where everything's going
you also have like some queen h6 here
eventually i mean this is like what is
going on depending on where the queen
moves but there's a scary stuff going on
to say the least
what is going on right so um of course
boo goes for bishop takes
a g4 actually taking um taking the
bishop after bishop f6
and then it was e at ef6 so here's the
next move taking the bishop getting rid
of it so again from the beginning here
rook f7 bishop takes g4 bishop f6 and
then he takes the bishop and says okay
cool i'm gonna take this bishop here now
you get my queen so what and we look up
and there's three pieces for the queen
usually this is pretty nice for the
person with three pieces but
unfortunately they're not open this
bishop is hitting air in a way
everything's blocked up right look at
all this blocked up plus we're about to
get a pawn right now which is captured
boom takes it and you can't even really
do much about this this is like
really ugly here really ugly i mean you
could go bishop f8 to be honest um which
is uh surprising the move here is a4
bishop 8 is actually a move that you can
play after f7 you do have to worry about
this weird check here but you have to
stay here and you're just passive the
entire time but at least you have the
pieces i mean at least you have the
pieces still you can't queen this yet
but this did not happen in the game in
fact after um rook takes d7 again let's
run through it takes bishop takes e
takes f6 black decided for a4 and just
said all right cool cut my losses here
i'm going with a4 which is actually just
worse because we are giving up more
material here and now there's only two
for the queen which usually you know
that's not enough right so let's let's
finish the the rest of the game here
king f2 h6 and there's about uh 15 moves
or so here so king he won rookie six and
he shoveled around and the goal here is
to obviously move the king somewhere
safe and use the queen and the pieces as
much as we can to finish off this game
this is going to be a a technical win
it's going to take a lot of time you see
how you move this king from g1 and walk
the king all the way over here to this
side of the board there may be sacking
potentials on c6 eventually king g7 king
b6 got the king all
came
fighting king right king fa queen f2
rook g6 queen f5 h5 and g3 and this is
where the game ends the rest of the pgns
over here so we're assuming resignation
h4 is coming to as well picking off the
h5 pawn king is in range i mean it's
just annoying it takes technique but
this was number one from a job off whoa
that was nice this was number one now
let's move on to number two here we go
guys with number two this is team or
rajabos number two top five so here we
go this is a visual one of the not oh
yeah the man himself the man the myth
the legend no one else right
vishwanathan or not versus timor or
jabba if you're playing black here as
black to move your queen's hanging take
some time pause the video if you got to
figure this one out it's black to move
what do you do
let's take stock what's going on my
queen
is hanging
it's out there you need to do something
so we're going to move the queen rights
so let's see what we have we could take
the pawn but there's this two for one
idea right queen takes rook takes so
he's getting two pieces for that
what if we move the queen maybe backward
maybe try to pin him this way rook takes
d4 right maybe queen b6 nice little pin
right pin the wheel looks spicy there
and then vision v3 ouch
doesn't work so you're still losing
material there wow so what does timor do
in this position what do you do you're
going to lose material so he says you
know what i'm going to take f4 on the
way off i'm going to lose something i'm
at least going to take something on the
way out but instead of rip takes d4
right which is actually going to be
answered by queen f2 believe it or not
queen f2 oh my goodness what a move
keep this in mind okay guys keep this in
mind right keep this in mind
rick that did not happen because there's
a nasty queen f2 move
but
anon says i'm going to play rook f2
instead
to attack this fleet
it is now your move
black to move
what are you gonna do
here it is here it is
well we know the saying right
okay my queen's hanging
when your queen is hanging
best practice says is hanging twice by
the way when your queen is hanging
best practice says says puts in the chat
if you remember this
best practice says what when your
queen's hanging
you should suck it
suck the queen oh my goodness squeeze
him what is he doing he's like the queen
bro oh my goodness the usually let me go
back if rook f2 i'm going to say this
one line if rook takes d4 in this line
right here if rook takes d4
right the knight is gone so pay
attention to this so if queen f2 now oh
my goodness king takes bishop takes d4
and he's like oh wow that's cute oh
that's a little check what starts off as
a double check and if king e2 it's mate
oh my goodness
mates rook f2 is made so if king into g3
okay could i was killed little queen
sack that was sweet right you ever seen
this mate
get it off the screen
get it off this greater mess made it
with two bishops oh my goodness this is
a family channel let's just get this off
the screen there could be kids watching
so that is gross um so in fact that did
not happen rook f2 was the move here
rook f2 and after rook f2
same thing we sack the queen after king
takes we now don't have bishop d4
now what do you do now what do you try
the other way well in fact you're
blocking with your whole face there
bishop h4 is a checky pool what to do
and i'm just going to step out of the
way and go like
thank you
that was garbage right that didn't work
so after king takes f2 you have to find
the next sequence of moves here it is
black to move what do you do now
this is utter chaos and he finds this
move right here
i'm out
i'm done for the day
this is a wrap
close off the video you can stop right
here this is like top five all his top
five moves in one one move here this is
crazy knight b5 this is beautiful not
only attacking knight c3 right the
bishop can take this you're going bishop
d4 check next with the same line that i
just showed you if you take with the
knights okay night night have a good
night not a good night for you bishop d4
check double check sheesh king e2 rick
up two's mate king g3 bishop two maids
bro this is a nod you can't be doing
this to this man like this right so this
is knight b5 after knight b5 after
knight to b5 and anan realizes the
danger says i gotta get out of here bro
you're not about to do me like this on
national television and put me in the
books forever so king g1 right he's he
gets out away have a nice day none of
that so of course honestly guys there is
like 15 moves left from right now so
we're going to fly through the move so
we can do the rest of them but what
happened was knight takes c3 knight
takes bishop takes takes stock of the
position we sacrifice the queen but look
we got two pass pawns engines give this
as plus 1.2
but as an engine they see all they know
all right they know everything so as a
human this is much harder to convert
from the white side because there's two
past pawns i have all of my pieces
besides one minor piece
all for a queen i mean i'm gonna take
this all day right so in fact uh bishop
takes c3 bishop b5 and anon was uh uh
was unsuccessful playing this uh
correctly of course as any many humans
would like this is a very hard position
to play from the white side bishop takes
e1 queen takes now when we got the two
rooks and all of this this is great and
just say it's super equal now but we got
the definitely the the two pass pawns
knight at five we're trying to reroute
our pieces and get a rook to an open
file makes total sense right and as we
fast forward here let's just see the
play and watch how the pawns start
rolling right now pawn roll there we go
pass pawns must be pushed there's all
kind of mate threats and stuff so b6
pass pawns must be pushed king h2 pass
pawns finish the sentence
must be pushed there we go d3 queen
before pass pawns
you should get this but you should get
the hang of this by now right he too
we're just pushing walking the dogs in
the park very easy i'm in the bishop to
c3 and now pass pawns
don't push that pawn don't push that
bomb
don't push that pawn okay you're gonna
lose both of these bombs if you push
them so he plays rook takes c3 and gets
rid of it queen takes it knight g3
threatening some mating threats whoa and
i'm about to clean i mean this is
disaster like wow with a queen on the
board oh my goodness b7 rook takes b7
and queen a5 with the idea of setting up
some type of perpetuals if you're not uh
careful or you're not looking so rook to
ba what a simple move just to stop all
your little checky pools just get them
checks out the way and game is over what
a game from a drop off that was amazing
that was number two let's move on to
number three okay guys here we are with
number three this one is shiroff oh
alexis shiro versus timor job off black
to move in this position we are in check
i mean it looks like we getting made it
right you playing cheer off and this
looks scary i mean this is just uh this
is another day in office for sure offer
here but a lot going on do we move the
knights and block it
right and lose the queen
now of course this is a check so we
wouldn't really lose it there but
do we give it up or do we run for the
heels can you have seven and try to run
for our life
what do we do
and this position is black to move
you're in check you're also playing
sheer off here whoa what is going on
here we go guys look check this out
so you're in check right we need to deal
with this we could go king of seven it
is actually possible it is very possible
but there is a lot going on though
bishop takes d5 i mean it's a little
scary kingy a rookie six
king d7 i mean
if you're not sure about this like you
know this is like probably the scariest
thing you've ever seen right it feels
like you are going to get made it there
also may be some perpetuals all type of
checks don't go this way i mean you
getting made it right so it's scary it's
very scary timor realizes this and says
you know what cool knight g3 jack
yeah all day and every day
all day and every day you can't take it
with the pawn which forces rook takes g3
check boom that's a check as well right
nice little check cool you could take
the queen of the pawn so we sacrifice
our queen back
f takes g3 rook takes h4
right but now look at this
am i just losing
well wait a second i got two pawns on
here on the third rank on the third rank
wow
okay so after g2 check king to g1
f2 check king takes g2 and now what do
you do chad what do you do you're
watching this
you're tied down
you can't move nothing
what do you do
how does seymour win this does he win
this you'll find out we're about to see
right now f1 queen boom right that's a
nice move diversion you have to take
this and after taking wait a second hold
up you got two bishops i have two rooks
i can move one now rook d2
kj iii takes we have a p sorry up in
exchange excuse me we're up in exchange
here but this is not cl it's clearly not
over obviously we still have work to do
as there's four pawns versus three and
the two rooks versus the rook and the
bishop if there were less pawns on the
board i mean this would be very close to
a draw but in fact it is not and bishop
c4 check king g7 bishop b3 locking stuff
up and defending b4 as well then we play
rook to b8 number to b1
checking possibilities maybe maybe even
trying to keep the king uh locked up
over here if we could trade a pair of
rooks it'd be good to go king g2 in many
cases rook c8 king of three rooks c3
check king goes to g4 we go over to f1
king h5 and then king f6 and there was a
resignation here in fact because of
course we have many ideas like backing
up this way you have rook g1 you also
have work four and you'll see up here
here
in many cases there's a lot of ways to
win here actually so um but with that
being said this was number three from
rajaboff looking shiro up here again
from the beginning that was pretty cool
seems like he was in a lot of trouble he
plays knight to g3 boom right
sacrificing the queen back saying and
this is pure calculation right you have
to calculate all of this out even seeing
f1 check in that whole line i mean his
calculation is next level sheesh after
takes he saw all of this and was able to
get some position and something greater
than what he got in the beginning there
and was able to win this game that was
shira versus job off number three now
let's move on to number four
here we go guys we're job off number
four teamwork with job office number
four of the top fives this one is
against alexander bortnick oh we know
who that is if you don't know
that's okay look just google it right
we'll forgive you we'll act like you
never have alexander bortnick playing
with the black pieces and timor rijab
off with white it is white to move as
you see we have some type of king side
attack here
some type of king side attack i mean
look at the bishop here if we can get to
g7 right man but the knight is defending
that very well
also i mean this kind of looks loose
maybe we sack a rook or something maybe
maybe rook sack maybe bishop takes maybe
bishop before maybe queen jack maybe
queen h6 what do you do
right
here's the move guys
so
here's another rule that we like to give
here at the channel on chess.com when
your queen is not defended or when your
queen is not being attacked right i
remember reading this vividly when your
queen is not being attacked
it is okay
to sacrifice it queen takes h5 check
absolutely if it's you can sacrifice it
when it's being attacked and when it's
not being attacked right
h5 is the move oh my goodness who was
thinking of this one i don't think many
people would have saw this one i mean
you're looking at in this check rook
takes
bishop takes who
who in their right mind or wrong fathom
this one queen takes h5 oh my goodness
were you looking at that one i'm going
to be honest i did not look at this one
queen survived i mean of course at the
first glance but here queen takes h5
this is not what you're looking at
you're not looking at this one queen
takes h5 bishop takes and now you have
to find the follow-up right bishop takes
h5 check king g8 cool we got an easy
check here rook g1 have to block because
you got the bishop on the other side of
the board criss-crossing like this right
obviously you couldn't go to e6 because
of the pawn so knight g's having his
fourth boom rook takes g7 now we got a
nice little windmill here beautiful
right and then it says okay wait a
second rook takes rook takes c7 right
because there's mate you have to block
with the rook if you go king g8 you get
mated how well king g8 rogue g7 king hay
and rook anywhere anywhere on the g file
doesn't matter rook f6 and bishop f6 is
mating so rook f6 was literally forced
literally forced so rook
sorry um so after rook takes e7 rook f6
and then we take the rook king to goes
to g8 rook g7 check if you go here you
get mated so it forces king to f8 king
f8 then rook takes h7 with the main
thread on the board that you can't even
stop really right you could go queen g4
but come on now
queen g4 really
really queen to g4 okay
got it seymour will drop off
and you go like lindsey
so this is not actually you're not gonna
play queen g4 in fact what he did play
was queen of five was just allowing kj
jackman this was just game over like
there was no way out of this to say the
least i mean that was absolutely
brilliant super strong stuff from uh
from team over job off and this is only
the beginning of it right candidates is
right around the corner
man this stuff is nasty queen takes h5
check oh my goodness out of all the
possibilities queen takes i mean rook
takes you're thinking of all day rook
takes rotate like i mean i'm not even
honestly guys like this just looks so
good right rook takes h5 but in fact
there's queen five that kind of helps
helps there weirdly enough but uh queen
h5 bishop takes takes king g8 check and
then take again and take on e7 i mean
look at this this is just oh my you know
let me get this off the screen this was
number four we're gonna move on to the
last one okay guys here we are with the
final one another one from these guys
rejava versus ananda the other time it
was a nine versus rajab off so now where
jabroff has white against vishwanathan
ana you guys know that is the legendary
monster former world champ we already
know right anon playing black
rijaba playing white take us the stock
of the position what is going on pause
the video if you need to it is right to
move what are you doing this position
let's take stock what's going on so we
gotta open rook file first off what's
black threatening both of these nights
here we are definitely going to be uh
it's trouble if you move the knight the
wrong place but we could capture but
then maybe that allows queen takes c4 i
really don't like the knight on c6 it's
some stuff we have to handle here though
these knights are kind of weirdly placed
could be attacked or they are attacked
right now
king's kind of in the center but we have
some pressure though like we got some
pressure maybe the d file files open
looks like some type of sicilian
happened here right you know so what do
you do though
what do you do
so many moves
here it is i hope you're ready for this
and this is why we say the best
for last here it is now
there's a lot going on
i have some pieces and stuff hanging
so i'm gonna just
second piece why not
sacrifice a bees you're always gonna see
this from a job off like what else did
you think he was gonna see knight takes
e6 threatening knight c7 checkmate this
is nasty if you take on e4 well i have a
good day there right
won't be living anymore knight c7 is
checkmate oh man look at the bishop
right beautiful knight c7 checkmate
beautiful stuff right that's beautiful
so of course what about let's say
let's let's go with a pawn takes right
how about that
maybe a pawn takes pawn takes e6 right
did you forget about this bishop h5 boom
bishop h5 check uh oh my goodness get it
off the screen and get it off the screen
right now right now so knight takes e6
is beautiful that's a beautiful move
knight ac says boom
you can't take it you can't take this
one you have to defend against knight c7
which is checkmate right and then if you
go bishop e7 then i go knight c7 it
takes like your position is gross come
on now there's gonna be a wrap very soon
so anon says all right you know what i
got to close up this bishop it's the
bishop that's giving me all the issues
so he plays g5 so now right now
currently there are three pieces hanging
right now three pieces
what do you do about it
three pieces hanging right now
how do you get out of this
how do you get out of this right to move
what did teamwork do right here
here it is
oh man
when you got three pieces attacking
here's the rule when you got three
pieces being attacked
you just check i guess because there's
not a rule for that i don't know how he
got out of this one right you got three
pieces of attack
no rule to that one knight of six jack
was the only move in this position the
best move in fact knight f6 jack is the
move right if this is a nasty move of
course if knight takes up scissors look
at every line king d8 not possible king
e7 runs into checkmate in one queen d6
is checkmate look at these pieces here i
mean how is he doing this to these top
level players like whoa and then knight
f6 um
you also have knight takes there's only
two moves you have king e7 and knight
takes f6 we just looked at king e7 and
knight f6 is a very natural move it also
opens up the bishop but unfortunately
that leads to mate two after 90s knight
c7 king e7 and queen d6 with the same
mate um here in the pawn defending i
mean beautiful checkmates here by
rajaboff here ending that on the spot so
again the combination with knight takes
e6 threatening knight c7 checkmate
if g5 which was well actually what was
played knight f6 ends it i mean these
knights going crazy here and that was it
in fact in fact after knight of six
anan resigned right here in this
position sheesh that's gg because again
after uh king e7 there's queen d6 mate
and after knight f6 there's knight c7
king e7 and checkmate these were team
over zappos top five the cannabis is
right around the corner guys hopefully
you guys enjoyed this and we're hyped
about it and all that stuff just like as
height as i was about looking at these
top fives guys so hopefully you enjoyed
it if you enjoyed this one make sure you
guys check the next one right above me
we'll see you on the next video